what are some experts saying about the
macroeconomic growth here's jamie dimon
jamie dimon is a person that's very much
highly respected in the financial
industry
american billionaire he's the chairman
and ceo of jp morgan chase largest of
the big four american banks since 2005.
uh j.p morgan chase has roughly 3.11
trillion dollars of assets under
management and ready 270 000 employees
believe me he does not want to see his
270 000 employees get hurt and he knows
this is coming diamond was previously on
the board of directors at the federal
reserve bank of new york so if anybody's
got
an idea of what really is going on on
the inside it's this guy there's three
things he's concerned about the fed
ukraine as well as all the other uh
commodities that we're dealing with
today now i want you to read what he
said in an interview i believe just last
week this is just a few days ago he said
this i want to read this to you nearly a
third this is a statistic to know about
commodities and then we'll go into what
he said nearly a third of worlds wheat
and a fifth of world's corn
both come from ukraine
let me say that one more time a third of
the world's wheat
and a fifth of the world's corn both
come from ukraine okay
that is deeply concerning we got nearly
200 different countries in the world the
smaller the country called ukraine has a
third
of world's wheat and a fifth
of corn both coming from ukraine so
here's future of oil prices and what
jamie dimon thinks is going to be
happening
currently it's somewhere around 100 okay
jp morgan chase suggests that oil prices
will rise to 125 a barrel in 2022 and
even further to 150 a barrel in 2023
breaking a record of a high of 147 147
and 27 cents
in the financial crisis of 2008
and you know what that means what are
you paying for gas prices right now
if it goes up another 50 percent just
add another 50 percent to your gas
prices because 50 on 100 is 50
so if you're paying six dollars gas in
la it's gonna be nine bucks
if you're paying seven dollars a gas in
san jose it's gonna be ten dollars and
fifty cents if you're paying four
dollars in texas it's gonna be six bucks
but regardless this is not a guy
who submits to fear porn
as dave ramsey says this is jamie dimon
this is not a regular guy okay when
jamie dimon speaks when michael bury
speaks when some of these guys speak
it's their business it's in their
interest for the market to not crash
you have to listen to them
this is reality this is data what you do
with it is on you you can read this
and say i totally disagree with jamie
dimon and then go read norman vincent
peale's book the power of positive
thinking and not want to think about the
barrel going to 150 then that means
you're partly naive but guess what maybe
it's going to make you feel good but
when it goes to the prices that jamie
dimon is predicting it could go to don't
be upset and don't complain about it
because somebody told you it could go
there it's on us to predict
prepare
persevere let me continue and again
stick around till the very end because
i'm going to have this pdf for you and
some of you guys going to get the entire
powerpoint that you're going to have i
think it's 108 slides that
a few of you guys will get so hang tight
to the very end so now
factors playing a role opec oil
production war in europe lockdown in
china those three are what's going to
cause this to be taking place and that's
what based on jamie dimon is saying i
want to read you what jamie dimon says
in an interview the guy's asking him
what do you think about going on right
now with the economy here's what he says
right now it's kind of sunny
things are doing fine
everyone thinks the fed can handle this
diamond said at bernstein conference
that hurricane is right out there
down the road coming our way
the entire place was silence
let me read this part to you one more
time
right now it's kind of sunny
things are doing fine
everyone thinks the fed can handle this
that hurricane is right out there
down the road coming our way we just
don't know if it's a minor one or a
superstorm sandy you better brace
yourself diamond said
non-benign environment and bad outcomes
he said the economy is distorted by
inflation he's also worried that the fed
is starting to unwind its bond portfolio
process known as quantitative
tightening which i'll explain to you
here in a minute at the same time it is
rising interest rates raising interest
rates that's something that the market
is not prepared for diamond said adding
that people will be writing about this
in the history books
50 years from now
folks
he doesn't benefit from saying this
this doesn't help his earnings like you
know how some people are supposed to say
real estate's going to do very good and
they're in real estate
uh real estate's not this is just so you
know well not gonna happen nothing's
gonna happen in real estate and your
son-in-law is in real estate you're
trying to protect this business so he
keeps growing because people are
watching you
but real estate's gonna go through this
if somebody said oh let me tell you
something it's don't even worry about it
everything's going to be all right and
it's in your benefit to get everybody to
think everything's going to be all right
if you own tesla and you're shorting
tesla
if you say i think tesla's going to go
out of business and they're not going to
do good because elon musk is not a good
ceo
you have incentive you have a motive
behind it you're shorting tesla
he doesn't benefit from this folks
that's jamie dimon so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]